what do you love about being a director
it's a good question I mean this is this
might sound cheesy but enough I've said
this before like a kaanum like you
should I should I start this it kind of
goes back to just the experience of me
being 13 and seeing something so
completely inspiring as Jurassic Park
and again like that if the if that film
hadn't been made my life would have been
completely different like if I hadn't
seen their movie like the Dead Saturday
afternoon look put me on a very specific
path in life if that hadn't happened I
would have not moved halfway across the
world I would have gone to USC I would
have met you know hundreds of
interesting people here in LA I wouldn't
be speaking English 24/7 but but you
know I would speak in German and I would
have never made this movie as a matter
of fact none of these people that I met
on this movie would have ever met each
other it's just insane how like this
snowballs just because someone made a
movie and I'm not saying I'm gonna make
sure as a park but it's just that's
absurd because it's so good
but the idea and maybe that's just me
being sentimental the idea that
something like a movie you know that
it's like that someday
somewhere on in this world some kid
might see the thing you've made and
respond to it in a certain way for
whatever reason and then decide to like
pursue a certain path in life that's
pretty wild you know I mean you're
you're like to affect someone's life
like that with something like a movie
you know we're not it's not brain
surgery but like I just like and again
maybe this will never happen it was just
me being sentimental but I just I like
that this that this could happen you
know yeah and I think like I said before
just because my life is very structured
and organized on normal days you know
there's there's a routine to to to
direct them to be on set it Yanks you
out of that routine and you know you
kind of just get thrown in the deep end
of the pool and it's exciting you know
it's thrilling also because so many
things could go wrong again it just it
just kind of feels like you're you're
parachuting out of a plane
you know it's it's like a little
adventure and you know even on this film
there there was like on any production
there was moments where there was a lot
of tension and people you know bumped
heads but I would always tell him it's
like you guys we could be sitting in an
office right now you know do 9:00 to
5:00 and down there home
we're in Vernon crawling around in this
creepy neighborhood telling a story like
how amazing is that you know and
oftentimes like that's what people click
with people and they're like yeah you're
right like this is it's like and every
day is so different you know like
there's no day that's just like the
other one because you're at a new
location there's new actors you doing a
new scene and she's an amazing job I
know that's not even look at it as a job
it's just yeah it's just you you you
just feel very alive doing that it's
like you feel like my god I'm that
you're now you're living life you know
because it's so the opposite of routine
it is it to the sense of possibility
that everything could totally fail and
there's that challenge of trying to keep
it from not feeling it's almost like a
game yeah and I mean I think maybe when
I say you feel alive maybe that's just
the anxiety of like oh my god everything
could go wrong you know but yeah it's
just it's like you just feel very awake
you know I mean you obviously don't want
it to go wrong but um yeah I don't know
I just I look I look at it as like a
little adventure
so then on the flipside what do you
dislike about being a director I mean I
guess I guess it's do it and as we've
addressed it before a little bit it's
the waiting game it's the stuff between
the directing where it's just like you
know you're getting your stuff out there
you're hoping it's gonna click with
someone and it's a lot of waiting like
you know again because people take you
know weeks to get back to you so it's
once once the ball gets rolling it's the
most awesome thing it's just the
in-between you know
because especially as freelancer which
freelancers which is what this is you're
always and I know a lot of actors and
and editors still feel the same way you
think you're never gonna work again
every time you're not working you know
you're like you're like this is the last
time I'm never gonna get another job so
it's like the downtime is no fun no but
that's you try to fill that at that time
with like creating new stuff getting
things ready so like when you when you
like meet that next person that wants to
make something you have things to show
me know I've heard some people say they
like that not knowing that in between
because you know if someone has had a
nine-to-five job it's like an endless
just calendar full of you know exactly
what's gonna happen and oh pointless
meetings and meetings about meetings
when you have a nine-to-five job you
mean the downtime den know when you
don't have that if you've ever some
people enjoy that not knowing there
there's something very thrilling about
even though it's scary there is
something you so you're saying like hi
even similar I guess then yeah yeah yeah
cuz you don't know there's like a sense
of possibility there's a sense of
unknown and I don't know if that's true
but at the same time when you're when
you're actually making it and you're on
set like there's there's forward forward
movement in and when there's downtime
even when you're making stuff there's
not necessarily any of that you know
what I mean because you might be down
for two months and
at the end of those two months you're at
the same place here we're two months
before once you get on a set and you're
actually making a movie two months later
you have something like something I made
you know so it just feels like there's
some forward momentum like things are
happening things are being made yeah I
like being productive at the end of the
23 days shoot when you wrapped what was
your when you were driving home from the
hole 10 minutes from the set or wherever
you were how did that feel oh it's funny
because I talked about this yeah it's
it's really weird just because like I
mean it was actually an emotional drive
home because it's the first time there
was the first time in like two months
that things slowed down for me to be
like oh my god that this just happened
you know how like life is like a series
of like milestones and it's not that
many you know like for me moving to LA
was one of them you know for other
people getting married having children
did you know there's a handful of these
milestones and like for me since since I
was 15 or 13 like this had been my goal
and often times you know I was quite I
was obsessing over it and like I I'd say
I probably sacrificed you know a lot
just to really focus on this and then
for it to you know what is what was that
like pretty much 20 years later for debt
to actually happen it was like this
weird feeling of calm because like all
of a sudden like everything kind of well
it was 20 years of like you know you
have your eye on the price and like
every day you're working on that goal of
getting a film made and then all's on
that film has been made and you're like
oh my god now what like it was like on
an emotional level it felt like life
could now go into a you know a million
different ways like don't know that I've
done this do I actually want to make
another movie
I mean like what am I gonna do next well
before that it was all like make a movie
make a movie you gotta make that movie
you know now you've made one and it just
felt like yeah it was it was almost
almost
there's liberating in a really weird way
you know but then you realize oh my god
I have to finish this movie and then
also you wanna you know you if you've
obviously learned a lot of things and
you're like oh my god I would love to
like apply all the lessons I learned on
this movie on making another movie and
do better next time
you know I don't boom your back on that
you know that that straight arrow you
know trying to make something else but
yeah I was like it's like just you're
like that you know the key a little call
like the eye of the storm for a little
while like everything just came to a
standstill and that was - that was me
and the car driving home from Griffith
Park in LA because that's been last
night we shot was in Griffith Park and
it was just driving home from Goa the
park to downtown where yeah it just kind
of I kind of realized like oh my god
like the thing I set out to do when I
was 13 just happened yeah because when
you're making a movie you're not
thinking of anything nothing like that
you know you're just trying to keep up
that's pretty cool were you by yourself
mm-hmm
yeah yeah was it late at night or was it
no it was lucky the Sun was coming up oh
okay was it was it was perfect because I
was a line through Griffith Park with
the Sun coming up behind the hills yeah
very cool
you